we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that came in over the last few
hours take a listen wow david that's
really interesting thank you do you were
probably the first person i've ever met
who doesn't take financial advice from
radio that's really interesting to do it
really really cool i understand this
this so this relates to i recently
mentioned when asked about financial
guru and religious right is dave ramsey
why I don't like Dave Ramsey and I gave
an explanation and then the follow-up
question was what radio P what people in
media do you take financial advice from
and I said quite plainly I don't take
financial advice from radio hosts or
people in media and the caller seems to
be mocking that like wow what a big
revelation David you don't take
financial advice from radio people I'm
shocked a lot of people do like the
premise of the question was if you don't
like Dave Ramsey which financial advice
people do you take advice from and I
said I don't take advice from people on
the radio or on TV I didn't really pick
up on that sarcasm but now that you
mention it I think it's there
I guess it's sarcasm right because it is
it genuinely shocking that I don't take
financial advice from people on the like
I don't even get the joke on you know
we're on the radio yeah oh I hear and we
say whenever we do like an icy overview
we ask about economics or what-have-you
this is not financial financial advice
and do your own research I don't under
if it's if it's someone genuinely
shocked that I don't take radio
financial advice then they just don't
know me that well
and if it's sarcasm that I don't take
radio financial advice I quite frankly
don't understand the sarcasm so a sort
of odd voicemail but yes what I'm
telling you is I don't give financial
advice on the show and I don't take
financial advice from other shows on
today's bonus show we will talk about
four women accusing New York Attorney
General Eric Schneiderman of physical
abuse we will talk about a type of
exercise that may help to relieve
depression and exactly as I mentioned
yesterday there are some things that
presidents do that have no impact on gas
prices there are some things presidents
do that can impact gas prices and indeed
Donald Trump announcing that the u.s. is
walking away from the Iran nuclear deal
as
caused a spike in oil prices which
presumably normally the way that works
is when oil prices go up eventually
gas prices also go up it's happening and
it is absolutely not
surprising at all all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show sign up
two ways go to join pakman.com and
become a member go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show and make a $5 a month
or more pledge and you will get instant
access to the world-famous world-famous
pad isn't that amazing of a myth world's
famous David Pakman show bonus show as
well as all of the other great member
benefits we'll talk to you then